we here at CBS News are committed to
stopping the stigma surrounding mental
health in taking the shame and the blame
out of discussing mental illness so this
morning we're hearing from four people
whose children died by suicide suicide
is the second leading cause of death
among teenagers in this country a recent
study found that teen suicide jumped 56
percent from 2007 to 2010 two health
experts say bullying and social media
have both contributed to the rise our
national correspondent that's Jericka
Duncan spoke to these four parents and
so jurika what do they hope to
accomplish by speaking up very glad that
they are what do they want to accomplish
they really want to help others that's
what all four of them said it comes down
to helping other people in our
conversation with these four parents we
saw incredible strength in the midst of
grief and each had a message of
awareness in Russell believe social
media is partly responsible for the
death of his 14 year old daughter Molly
Freddy Aviles 13 year old daughter
Rosalie died by suicide after he says
she experienced extreme bullying in
school kaamika Shelby's 15 year old son
Nigel died earlier this year after
coming out as gay and Carolyn's a no
lost her 18 year old son Cameron to
suicide in 2005 after he battled years
of depression and addiction it was such
a joy he was always being silly he loved
to dance he looked the same
roley's she was an angel she wanted to
be a lawyer and I asked her why do you
want to be a lawyer because I won't make
the world a better place
Cameron he was a very good artist
photographer generally just a very sweet
caring kid molly was adorable one of the
most caring people that I've ever known
and she was obviously also very good at
keeping secrets because she managed to
keep from us as a family that she was
suffering in this way we had no idea
statistics showed that in nine out of
ten suicides the person had diagnoseable
mental health issues raise your hand if
you believe your child had mental health
issues or had been dying
knows with the mental health issue yeah
definitely and I know now is that
bullying causes mental health they made
a video about her during school hours
the guy says oh look at this ugly girl
sitting over here by her cell and it
went viral inside the school and after
that that's look into a dark place and
that's when I started using her in
Molly's case was she bullied or you feel
like it was more social media the only
thing that we did find was on social
media which invited people who were
depressed into a club it invited people
who may have been self harming into a
club it normalized those behaviors it
just said time and time again I'm a lost
cause you're a lost cause
join our club and I do think she had a
sense of complete worthlessness at the
end of her life
his suicide letter he said I tried to be
normal but I couldn't it broke me he
said mom I can't african-american youth
are significantly more likely to die
from suicide compared to Caucasians why
do you think that is the pressure I'm
like you're going to go through a lot in
this world being a black man you're
going to go through twice as much being
a gay black men you does this make it
harder to process because they were
teens they weren't adults it's selfish
but I'm like well I'll never be a
grandmother never see him get married
and then that's purely selfish but it's
true they were going to graduation never
seen you get dressed for prom or become
the person she wanted to be it's hard
it's hard losing a baby when you guys
think back were there warning signs the
warning signs were a teenager spending a
bit more time and separating that
slightly normal awkward behavior that a
teenager has as they grow up from the
warning signs that can alert a parent to
the dangers of anxiety depression or so
side I think so hard for any parent to
do I just case was a little bit
different simply because he told me that
he was having thoughts of suicide I
started to take him to see therapist I
actually thought he was getting better
he had started doing normal stuff again
wanted to play with his friends and at
that moment when I finally started to
let up and I thought he was okay that's
what he really was and Carolyn you
experienced this loss in 2005 what
advice do you have to these parents here
today well the first couple of years you
know you're in a big fog you eventually
come out and I think all of us are out
to help other people I have become more
spiritual not in a churchy kind of way
but another way I know in Cameron's with
me probably like right now what do you
think he's saying right now that their
choice hurts us but they are in a safe
place they're okay
I know what Molly said in one of her
notes I love you and I know you love me
I'm so sorry but I just have to do this
I'll see you in a little while when
you're old and gray I want to be able to
talk about Nyjah story and hope that it
helps the next kid or the next parent
because I know he would have wanted me
to and a special thank you to those
parents for sharing their story
Ian Russell has been very outspoken
about the responsibility of social media
companies to police suicide related
content on their platforms just this
week Instagram strengthened its policy
and Freddy Avila is pushing for
Rosalie's law in California which would
make bullying a crime some of the signs
to look out for our isolation anxiety
substance abuse mood swings and erratic
sleep patterns the National Suicide
Prevention lifeline is one eight hundred
to seven three eight two five five it's
available 24/7 there was
not a dry eye and that was very much
behind the camera the producers that are
the things that's so tough to see is and
you hear this sometimes this year you
saw one mother say she thought her son
was getting better that's what scares me
and as a parent you think they are
getting better and then that happens but
also the warning signs are also things
that teenagers are doing anyway so it's
hard to tell what's really problematic
what's a real crisis and we spoke to a
psychologist before we interviewed those
parents and one of the things that they
talked about is people need to speak and
know that it's okay to ask questions are
you okay yes do you can ask are you
having oh yes yeah because you think
maybe you're triggering something but
you're not right it's so important that
we're having this conversation our
thanks to the parents who were so open
with jurika